on this morning's breaking news
concerning shamina Begum one of the
three East London schoolgirls who
travelled to Syria to join the so-called
Islamic state let's go to Alastair Bunko
and this is a decision in the British
courts Alastair what is it
it is this was an appeal by Shamima
Begum to reinstate her British
citizenship and she has lost the first
stage of that legal challenge so the
judge in the special immigrations
appeals court has decided to side in
that regard with the decision made by
Sajid Javid when he was Home Secretary
last year he stripped Shamima Begum of
her British citizenship because she also
is of Bangladeshi descent so they were
able to remove British British
citizenship which prevented her from
returning to this country from a prison
camp that she's being held in in Syria
now show me my Begum just to recap her
tale was 15 when she went to Syria in
2015 along with two other school friends
she joined Islamic state she married an
is fighter of Dutch origin they had
three children all of which died and she
was discovered in a camp called al Hall
last year by a number of media outlets
first by The Times newspaper but
interviewed as you can see here on your
screen by our colleague John sparks in
Syria a very violent camp because it
contains a lot of Islamic states
fighters and brides of Islamic state
fighters she feared for her safety she
argued through her lawyers in this case
that she was unable to properly put
forward her a caterer argument for this
appeal and that she was living in
squalid and inhumane conditions but she
has lost that to recap she's lost her
legal challenge to try and reinstate her
British citizenship and so this will be
seen as a victory for the government